i figured now is is a good time as any
to learn about probably what what most
people focus the most on when they
analyze companies and that's the income
statement and the income statement is
one of the three financial statements
that you'll look at when you look at a
company there's the income statement the
other two are the balance sheet which i
have drawn a lot in a lot of the other
explanations i've done on the financial
crisis and whatever else and actually in
this video we're going to see how the
income statement relates to the balance
sheet and of course the last one well
it's not of course if you don't know it
is the cash flow statement
cash flow statement
cash flow statement and we'll focus on
that a little bit later because that's a
little bit more nuanced relative to the
income statement so the income statement
is literally just saying how much a
company might earn in a given period and
it always was related to a period so it
would be you know for it could be an
annual income statement it could be for
the year 2008 it could be a quarterly
income statement those are usually the
two types you see but sometimes even
there's you know there's monthly or six
month income statements
and and the general format is is pretty
consistent although you know there's
there is a lot of variation depending on
what a business does but in this video i
really just want to cover uh almost a
plain vanilla income statement for a
company that just sells a widget so the
first thing when you sell a widget is
you know you you make it and you just
sell it right you sell the widget you
give a customer a widget and and they
give you some money
right and that money that they give you
and i'm not going to get too technical
about the accounting right now is
considered revenue
revenue
it's sometimes considered
sales
and that's literally the money that they
give you in a certain period of time and
some of you accountants out there is
like oh well no that's not just the
money that they give you it's the money
that you've earned in a certain period
of time and that's true but for our for
our sake let's just say that that when
you give the widget you have earned the
money that they give you and that's
revenue sales later on we'll talk about
different ways to account revenue and
sales so let's say the revenue or the
sales in this case in a given period
let's say that this is income statement
for
2008. so over 2008
we sold
i don't know
let's say three million dollars worth of
widgets
let me say let me do same color so let's
say it's three
million dollars
and a lot of times when you look at
income statements for companies if you
go to yahoo finance you could do this
right now instead of writing three
million though you'll see three thousand
there's like oh my god this company they
they're hardly selling anything but it's
kind of a
standard is that they tend to write
things in thousands so three thousand
would be three thousand thousands which
would be three million and for really
big companies they actually sometimes
write their numbers in millions so if
you saw three thousand there it would
actually mean three billion but
we'll actually look at real income
statements in the not too far off future
so that's how much money they give us
but that's not that's not how much
income we made because there was a lot
of costs that went into making that
widget that we have to account for it's
not like when someone gives me three
million dollars i can just say oh i made
three million dollars let me just put it
all in the bank i'm done that was all
all income so the first
thing that you tend to see on an income
statement is the cost of those actual
widgets the cost of producing those
widgets and those it'll it'll some and
i'll put all my expenses in let's do it
in magenta
so it'll sometimes be written as cost of
sales
cost of or cost of goods sold
goods
sold
and this is literally well there's two
things there's a variable cost which is
each widget they might have used some
amount of metal and some amount of
energy to produce it and some amount of
paint if it's a painted widget and so
the cost of goods is literally how much
did it cost to buy the metal and the
paint and provide the electricity to
make those those three million dollars
worth of widgets and then on that's the
variable cost and then on top of that
you have the fixed cost or maybe or the
relatively fixed cost where you know
just to run the just to have the factory
open it costs a certain amount of money
every year regardless of how many
widgets you make and we'll go into more
detail on that but for simplicity let's
say all of those costs of making the
widgets were
one million dollars
so sometimes someone might say it's a
one million dollar cost i like to when i
make models i like to put a minus there
so that i remember that that's a cost
anything that
that detracts from income i put as a
minus anything that adds is a plus
although that's not necessarily the
standard convention some people say oh
it's a positive one million dollar cost
which means you subtract but either way
i think you get the point
and then if you
if you
subtract your costs from your revenue or
if you just add these two numbers
because this one is negative you have
your gross profit
gross profit
gross
profit
in this case it would be two million
dollars
two million dollars
and this number tells you how much money
did you make did you or how much profit
did you make just from selling these
widgets so the you know the more widgets
you sell in in most circumstances the
larger
this number is going to be so this is uh
this is your profit before all of the
other expenses that a company has to
incur like the taxes and the ceo's
salary right the ceo salary doesn't go
in here right because the
cost of making a widget doesn't the ceo
doesn't go out there into the factory in
most cases and actually help make the
widget so the ceo salary or the cfo
salary or the the headquarters on in a
nice skyscraper that doesn't get
factored in here or the marketing
expense right you have to tell people
hey we make good widgets so none of that
is factored in here so that goes into
the next line and oftentimes you'll see
it bro broken up where it's you know
they'll have marketing expense
marketing
sometimes they'll have
as sometimes you have to pay sales
people so you might have sales expense
sales and then the stuff like the
corporate office and the ceo salary and
you have to hire auditors and
accountants and all that that might be
included as is general actually i should
be doing this in magenta because it's
all expenses marketing sales and then g
a you'll sometimes see sometimes you'll
see sg a g a just stands for general and
administrative expenses if you see sg a
sometimes instead of that you see s g n
a that means selling general and
administrative expenses selling is
things like
it could be the commissions that the the
sales people get it could be just the
cost of having sales people travel
around the country and taking people out
to stake dinners
you know and then the general
administrative that's just all the stuff
that the corporate office does and all
the people who are at that level
so if you subtract these and i'm just
making up these numbers as i go
say marketing the company is spending
i don't say it's my 500 000
and i'm putting it as a minus because i
like to remember it's an expense some
models you'll see they'll just write it
they'll say it's 500 000 expense
sales let's say
let's say let's say this is just gna
here i don't want to i want to make a
separate line for sale so let's say
sales selling expenses
is 200 000
and let's say g a the corporate offices
and all of that let's say that's another
300 000 dollars
three hundred thousand dollars
and now we're ready to figure out how
much money do the operations of this
business make so this is operating
profit
operating profit
this is really important to pay
attention to because so many people say
oh a company made this much and you'll
hear these numbers gross and operating
profit and net profit and pre-tax profit
and it's very hard to understand that
these are actually very very different
things because they all have the word in
profit and you know what does gross and
operating and all of that mean but here
you see it means very very different
things and let's calculate this number
first before i go off on on one of my
tangents on all the differences between
the operating and the gross profit let's
see 2 million minus let's see a million
my head i think implicitly made the
numbers work out nicely so my operating
profit here is 1
million dollars
so already we have some nuance on top
profit i made two million dollars just
from actual widget sales but when you
take out all of the overhead of the
company the marketing the sales the
general and administrative expenses i'm
only left with a million dollars and
this is the profit from the operations
of the company or you could say from the
assets or from the business or from the
enterprise of the company that's what is
generating but we can see you know i've
drawn a bunch of balance sheets before
and i think this is a good time to draw
a balance sheet
let me so you have kind of the assets of
a company
and we'll talk a little bit more about
assets and enterprise value or
and there's a little bit of a nuance
there but essentially the company itself
before you think about how the company
is paid for or how it's funded if you
just think about the enterprise itself
the assets
the assets are generating this
right they're generating the off
operating profit and that's a very
important thing to realize future in the
future when we talk about return on
asset actually we could talk about it
now if let's say our assets if we paid
if we paid let's say 10 million dollars
for these assets
and these assets this is the income
statement for 2008 are spitting out a
million dollars a year or at least a
million dollars in this year our return
on asset i wasn't planning on
introducing this but it doesn't hurt to
introduce it right now our return on
asset often taught
often acronymed roa return on asset
would be
well the numerator is the return which
is 1 million dollars
1 million the denominator is the assets
10 million
so we got 10 percent return on our
assets right for 10 million investment
we're getting a million dollars a year
we're getting 10
of our of our asset investment back
every year so that's a nice thing to
keep in the back of your mind this
return on asset concept and it's it's
very closely tied to operating profit
and and the actual assets of a firm
what we've learned and especially if you
want some of my other economics videos
that all companies aren't financed the
same a lot of them might have some debt
so let's say that company is a ten had
ten million dollars of assets but let's
say they paid for it
with five million dollars of debt
five million dollars of debt
and let's say the interest rate on that
debt is
i don't know maybe maybe think of a good
number let's say the interest rate on
that debt is
five percent
so let me make it yeah well let's sure
let's make it five percent
five i don't make it easier normally
make it ten percent interest right so
this is their operating profit this is
the money that just comes out of the
asset itself but of course that's not
the money that we get to take home
because we have to pay this interest so
let's throw that in there as an expense
interest
interest expense and obviously a company
that has no debt will have no interest
expense in this case we do and this is
an annual income statement so let's see
we have five million dollars of debt
and it's and we're paying 10 percent on
that
of five million dollars is five hundred
thousand dollars a year in interest
so we have to
essentially take half of our operating
profit
and give it back to the bank
and now we are left with our we're
getting we're getting close to where we
need to get to we're left with our
pre-tax income
and if we do the subtraction we're at
five hundred thousand dollars
five hundred thousand dollars and you
could guess what the next line is going
to be given that this says pre-tax this
is what the owners of the company get
before they pay the government
right so you can guess what the next
line is is going to be taxes
taxes let's say that it's a thirty
percent corporate tax rate so thirty
percent and you're going to pay take
thirty percent of this number right here
thirty percent of that number right
there so thirty percent of five hundred
thousand is a hundred fifty thousand
dollars
one hundred fifty thousand dollars
and then we are done we finally have
paid off everybody we need to pay off so
we started off with
three million dollars up here we kept
paying a bunch a bunch of expenses
and then now we're left with what this
is three hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
of net income
net income and this is what goes to the
owners of the company
this net income right here
so going back to our balance sheet we
had the 10 million dollar asset we had
five million dollars of debt we know
what's left over is the equity
so let me do that in a in a vibrant
color
equity is what's left over so the the
let's say this is all book value so we
have five million dollars of equity and
when i say book value that's just a
fancy way of saying this is what our
accountants say that we paid for the
stuff this is what we have on our books
and we'll talk later about depreciation
and amortization and how this how we
might change what these values are but a
very simple way is if you went out and
bought 10 million dollars worth of stuff
you'd write on your books i have a 10
million dollar asset and if you took a 5
million dollar loan then what you really
own if you were to kind of sell all of
this you would get 5 million
of equity
now this is an interesting thing when we
did return on asset we looked at the
operating profit because this is what
our company generated before we paid the
bank or uncle sam or anything like that
and so we we took this number as a
numerator and we divided by the number
of assets
now we can do another notion and that's
return on equity
return on equity so return on equity
and return on equity the numerator is
the net income that we got so it's three
hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and the denominator
here is the equity the book value of our
equity so that's five million dollars
one two three one two three let's cancel
some zeros out so it's like 35 over 500
35 over 500 is the same thing as 7 over
100 so it equals 7
return on equity and that's interesting
because well why that's lower is even
well i don't want to go too and too into
too much depth just because i realize
i'm already pushing my time limits but
at this point you should have a good
understanding of at least a basic income
statement of what of of of kind of a
company that sells widgets and in the
future we're going to look at a lot of
different companies financial companies
insurance companies uh
natural gas pipeline companies that will
have very different looking income
statements but this gives you the
general template for how things work at
least we'll give you a sense of what how
revenues gross profit operating profit
pre-tax income and net income really are
different and it's a lot of times in the
popular press they're all jumbled up as
just kind of the companies making this
much money anyway i'll see you in the
next video